good morning John I need you to do me a
favor go and get a coin and flip it ten
times actually everyone who's watching
this video right now pause it go get a
coin and flip it ten times now every
flip of every coin is going to be
entirely random but despite that fact I
know what just happened when all of you
flipped your coins I don't know what
happened to your coin but I know what
happened overall and that is because I'm
a psychic because I am omniscient
because I have a little camera installed
in all of your rooms and I watch you as
you watch me okay not actually it's
because I know about probability in fact
is this video will probably give you
tens of thousands of time I can
guarantee you that right now there are a
bunch of people who are like holy crap
man I just flipped going ten times and
it landed on heads every single time I
have a magical core and a magical Ison
ticket to Vegas and bet on it because it
always lands on heads but guess what my
friend there's nothing special about
your coin and there's nothing special
about you I'm sorry you're you're put
you're a beautiful snowflake you're very
special even if the odds of getting ten
heads in a row are over one and a
thousand which they are there one in
1,024 assuming that there are 100 and
2400 people who just flipped their coin
ten times there are roughly 100 people
who just flipped ten heads in a row and
100 people who just flip ten tails in a
row this is probability it is the
science the act nay the art of assigning
meaningful numbers to things that no one
can actually really no probability lets
us make real predictable and measurable
conclusions about random events a weird
thing about random events is that when
they happen once you have no idea what's
going to happen but oftentimes when they
happen many times patterns are obvious
and unavoidable so let's do a little
terminology now probability is just P
the event that we're looking for the
probability of is expressed by a letter
usually starting with a so the
probability of a happening is P of a and
if all outcomes are equally likely P of
a equals the number of events in which a
is true divided by the total number of
events so when you all hope your coins
each individual flip was entirely random
no one not Miss Cleo not Albert Einstein
not even dr. Manhattan could know where
that coin was going to fall but there
are two possible outcomes and getting
heads is one of those outcomes so there
is a 1 & 2 or 1/2
or 0.5 or 50% chance that it will land
on heads so when we flip a hundred coins
roughly 50 of them are going to be heads
and 50 of them are going to be tails and
we expect some variation around those
numbers okay
duh obviously but what if we're curious
what will happen when we flip two coins
then we're talking about the probability
of a and B happening very simply we have
a one in two chance twice and that is
one-half times one-half and assuming you
know how to multiply fractions that is
one-fourth a one in four chance that you
will get heads and then heads but then
if we're doing it 10 times we have
one-half times itself ten times which we
can write as one-half to the tenth power
which my calculator tells me is one over
1,024 this is how I could pretend to be
so smart before now let's take things
much more complicated and talk about
dice instead of coins it's not actually
any more complicated so if you're
rolling a die the total number of
outcomes is six and maybe we're
concerned with whether or not you're
gonna get a five that's one possible
outcome that's one over six holy crap
how crazy that you have a one in six
chance of rolling a five but what is the
probability of it not being a five that
my friends is called the opposite or
compliment and those of you who are
actually thinking about that will
probably recognize that that is one
minus P of a in the case of you not
rolling a five it is 1 minus 1 over 6
which is 5 over 6 so the probability of
not rolling a 5 is 5 over 6 this doesn't
sound complicated but the idea of 1
minus P of a being the opposite or
complement is actually very important
but if you want to know the odds of the
outcome being an even number then you
have to take all the even numbers 2 4 &
6 and put them over the total number of
possible outcomes and you have 3 over 6
which is 1/2 so basically it's a flip of
a coin so there you have it the outcomes
that you're concerned with over all the
possible outcomes but sometimes those
two numbers are really hard to come by
like it's really hard to figure out that
the number of possible poker hands is
two million five hundred ninety-eight
thousand nine hundred and sixty unless
you look it up on the internet which is
what I did and that's probably what you
should do in that situation too
and what about the probability of
getting two pair in your poker hand that
how the heck would you figure out out
well you don't you look it up on the
internet it's one hundred twenty three
thousand five hundred and fifty-two so
the odds of getting two pair in your
poker hand is 122 thousand five hundred
fifty-two divided by two million five
hundred ninety-eight thousand nine
hundred and sixty which is four point
seven percent it's so easy because
you're also very smart you probably have
noticed that
probabilities fall on a scale of zero to
one with zero being an impossible event
and one being a certain event and this
is why probabilities are often
represented in percents I assume that
you know this but percent is just like
saying something is out of a hundred so
when something happens one out of two
times the probability of 0.5 which is 50
out of a hundred times so we talked
about rolling a die and figuring out
what the probability of it landing on 1
twice is we're talking about the
probability of a and B happening which
is represented like this and is
basically like saying P of a times P of
B of course this is only the case when a
is not dependent upon what B is so the
probability of rolling Snake Eyes is 1
over 6 times 1 over 6 which is 1 over 36
the probability of A or B happening is a
completely different thing and that's
written like this and is basically P of
a plus P of B so the probability of
rolling a 2 or 3 is 1 over 6 plus 1 over
6 which is 2 over 6 which is 1 over 3
which is a 1/3 probability so now
because you are theoretically going to
have to use this newfound knowledge in
actual life somehow I'm gonna make up
some weird-ass situations that I have
nothing to do with real life and use
them to test your knowledge of
probability this is what we call word
problems and when I was in school I
hated them and they made me want to kill
myself but now I'm teaching them so I
frakkin love them first word problem
every time you smoke a cigarette you
have a 1 in 5 chance of being killed by
a terrorist and every time you have sex
before marriage you have a 40% chance of
being devoured by a tank of venomous
piranhas something as long as it makes
it up I should make up situations that
also have value judgments and are at
least a little bit interesting so if
you're not married and you have a
cigarette after you have sex what are
the chances that you survive I'm going
to give you a little probability tip
here
always go for ends and avoid ORS
so if we got to be the chances that we
die it's either the terrorists or the
piranhas that are going to get us and
that's an or and ORS are bad so make it
into an and and say in order to survive
we have to both survive the terrorists
and the piranhas but in order to do that
we have to do our 1 minus p of a trick
so we have our 1 minus 1 over 5 which is
80% and we have our 1 minus 40 which is
60% and we just multiply those two
together and get 48 percent one problem
number two you're at your mother's house
and you've been shot by a poison dart by
ninjas who just cut the power you go up
around to find the medicine cabinet but
your mother always mixes all the pills
into one bottle because she thinks it
saves space
which is done because there's a ton of
space in the medicine cabinet anyway
it's dark so you can't see the
difference between the pills and inside
the bottle there are six tylenols
for imodium a-d s and for poison dart
antidote pills you only have time to
pick three pills out of the bottle
before the poison that kills you what
are the odds that you survive I think
all we're problems should be life and
death okay so for those of you who
thought you were gonna avoid this
problem by just drinking the whole
bottle all at once you just died from
poison dart antidote pill overdose you
dead and you can't cheat your way out of
word problems so you're gonna want to
start this problem by saying okay I have
a 1 in 14 chance the first time in a 1
to 13 chance the second time and one in
12 cents the third time but then you're
doing or again it's either this pill or
this pill or this pill which you want is
and so you have to calculate your
chances of not getting an anthro pill so
your chances of not getting an antidote
pill are 10 and 14 times 9 and 13 times
8 and 12 you get 33% and then you just
switch back using 1 minus P of a and
it's 67% odds of surviving final word
problem you have a gun there's only one
bullet in it but you don't know which
chamber it's in you're being attacked by
a terrorist Velociraptor if you do
manage to shoot the Velociraptor is only
a 30% chance that it will stop before it
kills you you only have time to pull the
trigger four times what are the chances
that you survive again we must start by
counting the odds that we do not fire a
bullet five of six chambers are empty
click four or five chambers are empty
click three of four chambers are empty
two of three chambers are empty click
multiply all those together to get the
odds that you aren't going to shoot a
bullet that's 32% and 1 minus 32% is 68%
the odds that you will fire a bullet
then you multiply that by 30% to get the
odds that you will actually stop the
Velociraptor your chances of surviving
are 20% thank you for watching my video
John I look forward to seeing you
educate me more on Wednesday